Trascrizione: Francesca Milani
Revisore: Veronica Viscardi
Buonasera a tutti.
Sono una donna che lavora
ormai da diversi anni
e in questi anni si sono verificati
una serie di episodi
in cui mi sono state dette delle cose,
In quanto donna, sul lavoro
che mi hanno colpito o proprio ferito.
Si tratta di frasi, preconcetti,
che sono stati esternati
anche con leggerezza,
senza la volontà di farmi del male.
Me ne rendo conto, ma me ne hanno fatto.
Perché queste frasi, questi preconcetti,
saremmo portati un po’ tutti
proprio per cultura,
a esternarli quotidianamente,
ma è bene sapere che non sempre
sono opportuni
e che anzi potrebbero risultare
proprio svilenti o dolorosi
per una donna che li ascolta.
Nel tempo queste frasi, questi episodi,
mi hanno portato
a isolare una sorta di decalogo
delle cose da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando.
E ve le vorrei raccontare oggi,
proprio ripercorrendo insieme
alcuni episodi della mia vita lavorativa,
in cui queste frasi le ho ascoltate
con le mie orecchie.
Prima di iniziare
ci tengo a specificare una cosa.
Queste frasi che non devono essere dette
a una donna che sta lavorando,
non le deve dire un uomo
a una donna, certo,
ma non le deve dire nemmeno
una donna a un’altra donna.
Io questo proprio lo voglio sottolineare,
perché la mia non vuole essere
un’invettiva nei confronti degli uomini.
E quindi iniziamo con questi episodi
della mia vita lavorativa.
Per farlo partiamo proprio dal principio,
la mia prima riunione di lavoro.
Ho cercato una foto che fosse
il più possibile rappresentativa
della mia prima riunione di lavoro
e questa lo è,
perché eravamo proprio così.
Sette persone:
cinque uomini, due donne di cui una io.
Inizia la riunione e vedo che piano piano
le persone che presentano prima di me
si alzano e vanno a presentare
vicino allo schermo con le slide,
proprio come sto facendo io
in questo momento.
Capisco che anch’io avrei fatto
la stessa cosa.
Poco prima del mio turno
mi arriva un messaggio e lo leggo.
Il messaggio dice: “Tu non alzarti,
presenta da seduta,
altrimenti guardano solo te
e non ascoltano la presentazione.
Ora è la mia prima riunione di lavoro,
io leggo questo messaggio
e resto basita, incredula.
Per un attimo ci penso,
forse davvero non dovrei alzarmi,
ma poi rifletto meglio e capisco
che prima di me si sono alzati tutti,
quindi non alzandomi proprio solo io
darei un’immagine sbagliata di me
che non corrisponde alla realtà,
che non voglio dare.
Di essere timida, insicura.
Assolutamente no, io mi alzo.
Mi alzo e capisco
che chi mi aveva mandato quel messaggio
probabilmente voleva solo tutelarmi,
perché l’abbigliamento,
mi dispiace anche doverlo sottolineare,
ma castigatissimo che avevo scelto
per quella riunione,
non mi impedì di sentirmi
comunque praticamente nuda
davanti a dieci occhi che mi fissavano,
mi scrutavano e non ascoltavano
una sola parola di quello che dicevo.
Ho passato molto tempo
dopo quella riunione a colpevolizzarmi,
a pensare che forse l’abbigliamento
che io consideravo così castigato
in realtà non lo fosse affatto.
O che la presentazione che avevo preparato
non fosse interessante
al punto tale da aver reso
più interessante guardare me.
In pratica stavo facendo con me stessa
quello che si fa con le donne violentate
che se la sono andata a cercare.
Poi ho smesso.
Non l’ho più fatto, anche perché
negli anni mi è successo più e più volte
ed ero vestita sempre in maniera diversa,
presentavo cose diverse e soprattutto
mi sono confrontata con altre donne
a cui è successo
che a loro volta erano ovviamente
vestite in maniera diversa
e presentavano cose diverse.
Ho capito che non poteva essere
sempre colpa nostra,
anche perché chi mi aveva
scritto quel messaggio
l’aveva fatto prima
che l’episodio si verificasse
ma già sapeva che sarebbe andata così.
Ecco, per favore, smettiamola
di farla andare così.
È questa la prima cosa da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando.
Che sarà ascoltata meno
di quanto sarà ascoltato un uomo.
E questo vale in riferimento
al suo aspetto fisico,
come in questo episodio.
Ma vale in generale,
perché quante volte sono in riunione
ad un incontro con un collega uomo
e in automatico dall’altra parte,
come vi dicevo all’inizio,
proprio per cultura,
senza la volontà di fare del male,
ma ci si rivolge più a lui che a lei
soprattutto per quanto riguarda
le scelte strategiche,
come se la donna fosse
una sorta di assistente
di quel collega uomo,
anche quando in azienda
sono assolutamente allo stesso livello.
Non facciamolo più.
Ma arriviamo alla seconda cosa da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando.
Sto preparando un evento aziendale
per un cliente, sono con lui in riunione.
Sto presentando una serie di location
che ho selezionato
e tra cui lui può scegliere.
Per presentare le location con il dito,
proprio come sto facendo ora,
indico un dettaglio.
Vedo subito che lui, anziché il dettaglio
che io sto indicando, mi guarda il dito.
Mi sembra subito molto strano,
quindi istintivamente ritraggo il dito
e pongo entrambe le mani sulla tastiera.
Vedo che lui segue esattamente
la traiettoria dal dito alla tastiera.
Mi sta guardando le mani.
Inizio a guardarmele anch’io,
forse c’è qualcosa che non va,
sono sporche.
Lì lui deve giustificarsi e mi dice:
“No, scusa, è che hai
delle mani bellissime.
Non riesco a smettere di guardarle”.
Ora un cliente, un uomo,
tra l’altro di vent’anni più grande di me,
fa un apprezzamento fisico
nei miei confronti mentre sto lavorando,
e senza che io gli abbia mai dato
la benché minima possibilità
di pensare che a me avrebbe fatto piacere.
La situazione mi provoca un imbarazzo
tale che era inverno,
ma comincio a sudare in maniera copiosa
e mi ricordo che addirittura
mi è successa una cosa
che non mi era mai capitata
nella mia vita.
Avevo gli occhiali e per il caldo
si appannano completamente gli occhiali.
Me la ricordo come una delle situazioni
più imbarazzanti mai vissute
e tutto questo è scaturito dal fatto
che mentre stavo lavorando,
una persona si sia sentita legittimata
a fare un apprezzamento fisico su di me,
a dire a una donna
che aveva delle belle mani
in un momento in cui
non ero una donna con delle belle mani,
ma ero la dottoressa La Pertosa,
esperta di comunicazione,
consulente che stava presentando
un lavoro a un suo cliente.
E quindi eccola la seconda cosa
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando.
La generalizzo per non entrare
troppo nei dettagli.
Che è bella.
È un complimento?
Certo, può essere, ma non è detto
che a una donna sul lavoro
faccia piacere ricevere
quel tipo di complimento
quell’apprezzamento fisico,
anche perché questo porta istantaneamente
il rapporto su un altro livello
e non è detto che quella donna
voglia portare quel rapporto
su un altro livello.
Ovviamente non dovrei neanche specificarlo
sto dicendo di non dire ad una donna
che è bella, vale anche il contrario.
Ma andiamo avanti e arriviamo a un momento
molto felice della mia vita
in cui Luca, mio marito, mi aveva
appena chiesto di sposarlo.
Il giorno dopo sono da un cliente
e sto pranzando con dei colleghi
e delle colleghe
che sono molto carini
perché in pausa pranzo propongono
un brindisi per il mio fidanzamento.
Si unisce al brindisi anche
il responsabile dell’azienda che seguo,
quindi del mio progetto con quell’azienda,
nonché capo dei colleghi e delle colleghe
che stanno brindando con me.
Questo responsabile durante il brindisi,
con una nonchalance assoluta
davanti a tutti mi dice:
“Ora però
non fare subito un figlio che ti bruci”.
E poi aggiunge: “Ma tu sei una sveglia,
mica te lo devo dire io”.
Di questa sua esternazione agghiacciante
mi colpirono in particolare due dettagli,
uno più evidente, uno più subdolo.
Quello più evidente riguarda ovviamente
il fatto che una persona sul lavoro
si sia sentita legittimata a dire
a una donna
dandolo proprio per scontato
che fare un figlio
le avrebbe bruciato la carriera.
Ma quello più subdolo riguarda il fatto
che quando lui dice questa cosa
lo fa davanti a me e davanti
alle sue collaboratrici mie coetanee
e non può sapere se in quel momento
qualcuna tra noi
magari sia già incinta
e non l’abbia ancora detto
oppure stia pianificando
esattamente quello
che lui ci sta sconsigliando
di fare, cioè un figlio,
nonostante il fatto che siamo in carriera.
Non può saperlo, ma in quel momento
lui, che ha in mano
il mio contratto con quell’azienda
e che ha in mano
il lavoro di quelle collaboratrici,
sta esternando
che se noi decidessimo di fare un figlio,
lui ci considererebbe poco sveglie
e probabilmente della nostra carriera
penserebbe che ormai è bruciata
visto che ce l’ha appena detto.
Ecco, è assolutamente questa una cosa
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando,
che fare un figlio le brucerà la carriera.
E ricordiamocelo anche
quando parliamo di calo delle nascite,
di problema demografico in Italia
passa anche da considerazioni
di questo tipo,
esternate proprio così alla leggera.
Ma vale anche il contrario
di questa affermazione
e mi è successo in un episodio
che si merita addirittura due cose
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando.
Sono a un evento
e un collega mi presenta una manager
di un’importante rivista
business specializzata,
una di quelle che raccontano
anche storie di aziende,
imprenditori, imprenditrici.
Questo collega mi presenta così:
“Lei è una cazzutissima”.
Avete presente quando all’inizio vi dicevo
che ci sono delle frasi,
dei preconcetti che proprio per cultura
esterniamo con leggerezza,
senza la volontà di fare del male?
Ecco, questa è una di quelle.
Vi rendete conto di quanto
ancora oggi, spessissimo,
per fare un complimento a una donna,
per valorizzarla, le associamo
degli attributi letteralmente maschili?
Quindi una donna in gamba diventa
una donna con le palle,
con due palle così,
cazzuta, con gli attributi.
Ma perché ancora oggi abbiamo bisogno,
per valorizzare una donna,
di associarla a un uomo,
proprio dal punto di vista fisico?
È assolutamente questa una delle cose
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando,
che ha attributi maschili.
Ma ve lo avevo preannunciato,
questo episodio si merita
addirittura due cose
da non dire una donna che sta lavorando.
Perché io racconto la mia storia
a questa manager
e lo faccio con dovizia di particolari.
Ho tutto l’interesse a fare
bella figura con lei.
Lei è colpita dalla mia storia,
me lo dice proprio.
“Che bella storia”.
E poi aggiunge:
“Non dirmi che hai anche un figlio,
se no sei proprio incredibile”.
Questa donna vuole farmi del male?
È evidente, no.
Questo è un complimento nella sua testa,
ma vi spiego subito perché
può non essere un complimento
e anzi può essere proprio doloroso
per una donna ascoltare questo.
Io a questa manager ho appena raccontato
che a 18 anni ho lasciato Brindisi,
la mia città, e mi sono trasferita a Roma,
dove in parallelo ho studiato
all’università e a un’accademia di teatro.
Le ho raccontato che ho studiato
entrambe le cose,
con grande difficoltà e sacrifici,
ma che nonostante questo sono riuscita
a laurearmi con una media talmente alta
da essere premiata
alla Camera dei Deputati
tra i laureati più meritevoli d’Italia.
Poi le ho raccontato che in Sapienza
mi sono iscritta per la magistrale,
che sono stata premiata anche lì
tra i laureati eccellenti della Sapienza.
Le ho raccontato
che quando mi sono laureata
già lavoravo in consulenza
e che in parallelo coordinavo
due cattedre in Sapienza
sia di pubblicità
che di digital marketing.
Poi ho detto che quando la mia carriera
in consulenza andava molto bene,
guadagnavo bene, avevo un percorso
di carriera ben definito,
mi sono dimessa per co-fondare
una piattaforma di formazione online
che si chiama Carriere.it,
con cui vogliamo democratizzare
la formazione di alta qualità,
per cui eroghiamo decine di videocorsi
sulle competenze più richieste
nel mondo del lavoro
con i migliori professionisti italiani
a un prezzo accessibile a tutti.
E le ho raccontato che con carriere.it
si formano migliaia di persone
e che siamo stati premiati
come best knowledge business italiano.
Tutto questo ho raccontato
a questa manager
ma evidentemente per lei alla mia storia,
per essere proprio incredibile,
mancava ancora qualcosa.
Mi mancava un figlio.
Poi vi immaginate se in quel momento
un figlio stessi provando ad averlo
e non arrivasse,
oppure se già sapessi di essere sterile?
Oppure ancora se io, semplicemente
un figlio avessi deciso che non lo voglio
e avessi dovuto ascoltare dalla viva voce
di una manager così importante
che per lei, e per tanti altri come lei,
alla mia carriera, non avendo un figlio,
sarebbe mancato sempre qualcosa
per essere proprio incredibile.
A nessuna storia di nessuna persona,
ma di nessuna donna in particolare,
mancherà mai qualcosa
per essere proprio incredibile
se le manca un figlio.
E quindi è questa la sesta cosa
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando,
che non facendo un figlio
le mancherà qualcosa.
Ma arriviamo all’ultimo episodio
e io vi avevo preannunciato
dieci cose da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando,
quindi questo episodio se ne merita
addirittura quattro.
Vediamole insieme.
Sono in conference call con dei colleghi
e con il responsabile
di un’azienda che seguo.
Il responsabile ci preannuncia
che nella prossima riunione
introdurrà anche il direttore commerciale
di questa azienda e ci aggiunge:
è donna, è bravissima ed è giovanissima.
A noi incuriosisce molto il fatto
che ai vertici di un’azienda importante
ci sia una persona giovanissima
e quindi ci lasciamo con questa curiosità.
Ma evidentemente uno dei miei colleghi
questa curiosità
non la voleva nutrire a lungo,
perché va subito a cercarla
questa manager e la trova,
la trova e ci manda una sua foto
in una chat di gruppo
che condividevamo tra colleghi.
La foto ritrae una donna bellissima
che valorizzava al 100% la sua femminilità
con il suo abbigliamento sul lavoro.
Il collega manda la foto di questa donna
accompagnata da questo commento:
“Ah, ok, ora mi spiego tutto”.
Fino a pochi secondi fa
questo collega non conosceva
neanche il nome di questa donna.
Adesso era bastato vederla,
vedere che era una bella donna
che non castigava
la sua femminilità sul lavoro
per avere assolutamente
chiaro come avesse fatto carriera.
Tra l’altro noi questa donna poco dopo
la incontrammo effettivamente
come ci aveva preannunciato
il nostro responsabile
ed era bravissima.
Ci raccontò addirittura di conoscere
molto bene l’azienda
perché lei era partita
vendendo porta a porta come rappresentante
ed era stata prima
la più brava venditrice della sua zona,
poi della sua città, della sua regione
e piano piano era arrivata a fare carriera
e diventare direttrice commerciale.
Vi risparmio i commenti beceri
in quella chat di gruppo
dopo quella riunione,
e quali competenze i miei colleghi
attribuirono a questa povera donna
per essere risultata sempre
la più brava nelle vendite
andando di casa in casa delle persone.
Quello che capii in quella circostanza fu
che questa manager poteva raccontare
qualsiasi cosa della sua carriera,
dimostrare sul campo la sua bravura.
Ma per i miei colleghi la sua credibilità
avrebbe sempre avuto
un enorme peccato originale,
quello di essere donna, di essere bella
e di aver deciso di non castigare
la sua femminilità sul lavoro.
E quindi eccole le altre cose da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando.
Che sta dove sta,
perché l’ha data a qualcuno.
Che dovrebbe essere meno femminile
per essere più credibile.
Ma attenzione, vale anche il contrario.
Perché quante volte ho avuto
delle colleghe che al lavoro
preferiscono venirci in jeans e sneakers,
allora i colleghi a dire: “Certo questa
ogni tanto un paio di tacchi, una gonna”.
Ma se invece decide di indossarli,
quei tacchi e quella gonna,
non pensiamo che necessariamente
si veste come si veste
per piacere agli uomini.
Eccole le dieci cose da non dire
a una donna che sta lavorando.
Ma in chiusura mi piacerebbe
lasciarci con un'immagine.
Se vi va, chiudete proprio gli occhi
con me per qualche secondo.
Immaginate una persona che suona,
delle persone che ascoltano e un telo.
Potete riaprire gli occhi.
Cosa c'entrano insieme queste cose?
Non so se lo sapete,
ma fino agli anni ’70 nelle orchestre
la presenza di donne era
praticamente pari a zero.
Poi, dal 1970 la presenza
ha iniziato ad aumentare
fino ad arrivare ad avere il 50%
di nuovi  ingressi di donne
all’interno dell’orchestre.
Cosa è successo?
È successo che è stato posto un telo
davanti ai candidati
che si presentavano alle audizioni,
per cui chi doveva ascoltarli e giudicarli
non poteva più vederli, ma solo ascoltarli
e quindi non poteva più sapere
se stesse suonando
un uomo oppure una donna.
È bastato questo, non conoscere l’identità
di un candidato, di una candidata,
per far aumentare del 50% la probabilità
che ad essere assunta fosse una donna.
Ho voluto concludere così
questo mio intervento
perché io vi ho parlato delle cose
da non dire a una donna che sta lavorando,
ma è bene ricordarci che ancora oggi
per una donna arrivarci a lavorare
può essere un privilegio.
Grazie.
(Applausi)